ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
African Union we gave the press remarks
we will start with the chairperson of
the African Union Commission followed by
Madame Conda liar and then afterwards we
will have the family photo after we've
taken away the lantern the chapters must
speak in French thank you Bonjour shares
a be news of donor in the Brazil the
reservoir same attend the president Law
Commission did in Europe n here is their
visa premiere visit on door del Oro
pan-african come on sample new African
movie on so hungry it's a lot the Nazi
Lana B's one the son engagement it a
Laplace departing area anta Diop
elephant movie version Gustavo affair
repeat to do Rizzo
the porter connaissance a novel pre
rendezvous FF III a polar a know the
college a panellist don't Commission del
in European Commission didn't you
African casseras Vivi and sweet is a
light on the program in Iranian
ministerial a freak Arab a temperance
ship elephant the line-item in Van Buren
ensue me a freak Arab
Sanada not a girl ma na figure doe not
reportin area key important area
strategy on different domain the freak
cafe des progre
dance on integration economic politic no
tama avec rollins Ahmad Alhassan
deliberations continental Nozawa
important area a garma
tres ravine on the domaine de la Paix la
sécurité de la stability
do you owe terrorism and the criminality
transfer antalya a and then take this
mary review the criteria necessity you
know prevent ajar a vehicle in european
the mobilization de la communauté
internationale prefer fasten CD v
Kaituna - Aryan an appe and a stability
random on top not a Parton area avec
leur op milky form he ate residency a
condiment van Hooser no la profe until
the Vantage don't settle really jerky
the reservoir the president whose or VEC
this share person it has been now less
than a week since the European
Commission has taken office and Here I
am in the heart of the African continent
I have chosen Africa for my very first
visit outside of Europe I hope my
presence at the African Union can send a
strong political message because the
African continent
and the African Union matter to the
European Union and to the European
Commission for my first visit I have
chosen the continent hosting the world's
fastest-growing economies a continent
with immense ambition and aspirations
but also with immense needs and I've
chosen the African Union's headquarters
as the home of all African people from
Cairo to the Cape for us for the
European Union you are more than just a
neighbor
both our unions a built on a dream a
dream of peace and a dream of economic
prosperity in our continents
and therefore it is for me of utmost
importance that I also think that our
founders both in Africa and in Europe
knew that only unity could make our
continent strong in a changing world the
African Union is a partner I count on
and I look forward working with in the
spirit of a true partnership of equals
the chairperson today I'm not here to
present some grand plan for Africa I am
here first and foremost to listen I'm
here to listen to you chairperson I'm
here to listen about the trends shaping
Africa and the African Union about
developments across the continent about
political and economic priorities and
I'm very grateful for the intense
discussion we have had the exchange of
experience
I cherish your knowledge I could listen
to and therefore today it's a great
opportunity for me to introduce also
what we did in our debate the three
priorities I do have for the European
Union first of all first of all it's the
fight to stop global warming
we call it the European Green Deal the
second is a plan to make Europe fit for
the digital age and the third is the
aspiration to be a geopolitical
commission and on all three priorities
we've seen in our discussion that there
is room for greater cooperation between
Europe and Africa you hear on the
African continent understand climate
change better than anyone else you just
told me about the deserts of advancing
you told me about the floods becoming
more frequent and more violent but you
are also experimenting on new solutions
from the great green wall to
referre station for example here in
Ethiopia the digital economy is also
growing sector in several African
countries digital pioneers and tech hubs
are proliferating from South Africa to
Tunisia from Wanda to Ethiopia young
people are asking for more investment
better education stronger infrastructure
we've been talking about that but it's
necessary to invest in that and finally
we share the same interest in expanding
our partnership of equals we've been
speaking about security and peace and
your chairman just spoke about the the
content of our discussion both the
European Union at the African Union we
are multilateral structures by
definition and as such we can be the
backbone of the United Nations systems
but we also can be very strong partners
within the United Nations systems
sheperson
I have we have an intensity of
cooperation ahead of us I'm grateful
that you just invited us to a college to
college meeting at the end of February
presumably then followed by a manie's
ministerial and then followed by the
summit in 2020 in Brussels today I've
seen already that many of our priorities
and interest coincide as we've just
spoken about the interest and peace and
security the interest in we've been
speaking about the topic of migration
too
honestly I don't have all the answers to
these challenges but I'm convinced that
together we can find answers together we
can find and build solutions that work
for Africa and for Europe alike
chairperson gromicko infra Deborah merci
pour votre mère
Hospitality is esperan cooperation
transit what a big good only zania
veneer not reduce christian was that the
buddha vdsat especially repelled new
sunday wasa
buddha BD a news Evo desta comma merci
beaucoup